[Music]
Kennedy as we continued with reaction
all today's big stories and news author
of the number one New York Times
bestseller vengeance former Speaker of
the House Fox News contributor Newt
Gingrich so you have all of these cases
in some cases these sexual harassment
cases mistreatment of people cases and
some people admit it and then you have
instances where they do not that we are
hearing 15 million dollars a taxpayer
money was paid out by members of
Congress shouldn't the American people
they don't want to pay it themselves
shouldn't we know whose money who's
paying what where and how sure look I
mean this whole thing is if you back out
for a minute this whole thing that's
crazy it's it's a very good thing for us
to explore we're learning a lot of stuff
that's a huge surprise I don't see why
if it's a personal offense I don't see
why the taxpayers ought to pay a penny
and I think that that's something that I
really look at carefully in terms of
where have the taxpayers money gone to
cover up incidents like this but I also
want to take just a minute showing them
that maybe this makes me you know an
outlier or somebody who's out of touch
with the times I think there's an
enormous difference between Harvey
Weinstein who clearly is a sexual
predator and who clearly was exploiting
his position of power and President
George HW Bush who is in his 90s in a
wheelchair
and I think we have all these things
coming together because of the infantile
stupidity of our news media as though
they're all the same problem now the
topic is an important topic and finding
a way to have not just a workplace but
they have a community where people are
not being harassed or being preyed upon
I think that's important finding what
the rules ought to be and I commend
Speaker Paul Ryan who immediately
responded by talking about getting
mandatory training in the house I think
Senator McConnell's taken the same
position in the Senate I think we
deserve to know the American people who
did the money get paid out too
and who paid for it and why is the
taxpayer on the hook for any of this so
that part is a legitimate public policy
question what they wanted anonymity they
should have used their own dollars right
which they wanted to make a deal
they shouldn't that should be their
money no absolutely I and I think you're
going to find the same things happening
in corporations where people gonna be
very skeptical of the idea that you
could spend the stockholders money to
cover up things that the stockholder
didn't approve of you covering up but I
also think I think what was suddenly
done is we have unearthed a lot more bad
behavior and a lot more destructive
behavior than anybody certainly and I
would have thought was going to happen
including some very positive people I'm
actually shocked to see showing up in
some of these attacks what about the
cases where you there's no clear line
there's no Al Franken picture and you
don't know for sure we saw what happened
with the Duke Lacrosse kids and that's
one of just a number of examples where
so many in the media been so wrong so
often there's a risk here at one
allegation could destroy somebody and
it's not true or it's far more nuanced
that anybody wants to know yeah okay I
think it's time and then I'm again I'm
gonna go straight out on a limb about
this we've had a very long tradition in
America going all the way back to the
Boston Massacre in the 1770s that you
are innocent until proven guilty and
that you have the right of a presumption
of innocence and I think again if you
have somebody like Harvey Weinstein who
now has so many names out there that
it's almost inconceivable that isn't
guilty of a substantial amount stuff you
start getting this somebody remember
that 12 years ago they felt bad boy I
don't understand the standard that goes
into that and then how do you prove what
really happened and how do you prove
whether or not somebody really meant to
do something negative and I do think
we've got to take a deep breath here and
not have the hysteria allow us to start
destroying
people randomly so that you then set up
targets where anybody once you can get
even by suddenly remembering something
that happened 20 years ago it gets hard
to wouldn't there's politics in the
equation you know where you know Oh
Clarence Thomas's it would be a case in
point
last-minute allegations thrown out there
on the eve of a Senate hearing or on the
eve of an election in october surprise
george w bush the weekend before that
election without war the DUI came came
out so in the whole year and a half
prior nobody knew about that that wasn't
plan that wasn't a last-minute october
surprise to influence voters where
somebody doesn't really have a chance to
to help themselves or prove they're
there they're grown beyond an instant
like that well i think that's part of
its manipulation of the public by
liberal news media trying to make a
point part of it is i think that you've
got to look at some of these things and
ask yourself why are they why are they
coming up now what's the evidence and
again if it was in a situation that in
fact was basically innocent but is now
subject to misinterpretation when i when
I see people who weren't particularly
offended ten or twelve or fifteen years
ago but suddenly there's now this
hysteria and so they decide they're
going to join the lynch mob and they got
their story to tell I just think we as a
country to take a deep breath and and
and think carefully and again I say this
you know whether it's about my wife my
two daughters my granddaughter for that
might have my grandson because remember
you have many instances now of sexual
harassment that involves men as well as
women so I think all of us want to
protect the innocent but we also have to
remember that the innocent may be on
both sides of that equation and it's not
automatically clear that a charge is the
same as a conviction so Sarah Cardo is
gonna join us later tonight is now
reporting that this FBI informant this
guy worked for over four years for the
FBI
and knew about Vladimir Putin had
established a network inside of the
United States
goal was to crack into the uranium
market and he has documents he has
emails he has first-hand experience and
apparently even tapes Sarah Carter's
referring to it as a treasure trove of
information proving and that's where the
bribery and the kickbacks and extortion
and money laundering all took place
proving that that all happened and yet
that was 2009 before the approval of
uranium one it seems to now be cascading
the floodgates seem open how far should
this go is this something the Justice
Department can handle is this Special
Counsel area what do you think it you go
first of all notice the infantilism of
the american media today the next story
by somebody about something that may or
may not have happened 12 years ago as
long as a sexual boy that's gonna be a
big story here you've got an enormous
historic story you apparently have the
head of Russia in a methodical project
trying to gain access and influence over
Bill and Hillary Clinton while she is
Secretary of State trying to get control
of the American uranium market willing
to spend apparently well over a hundred
million dollars you have an FBI source
who apparently was ignored deliberately
by the Obama administration who is out
there saying wait a second guys look at
all this evidence I don't understand how
the House and Senate can avoid having in
depth weeks of hearings taking this
whole thing apart bringing a subpoenaing
everybody making public all the
information about the Clinton Foundation
about Bill Clinton's personal earnings I
mean how many different ways were these
folks were the Clintons making money out
of this and does anybody really believe
all this was innocent I mean I think
it's and it's astonishing and by the way
it goes beyond the Clintons it goes
right to the Obama administration to the
corruption of the Justice Department and
to a level of problems that I think are
truly historic all right mr. speaker
appreciate you being with us thanks so
much